"This episode of DNews is brought to you by
the all-new two thousand fourteen Toyota Highlander."
There are 7 BILLION people on the planet.
Which means there's probably someone out there
who looks JUST.
LIKE.
YOU.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
2 strangers who are completely unrelated and
look exactly like.
Doppelgangers are a trip and are found all
over the world allllll the time.
Our understanding of doppelgangers has taken
on a more casual understanding this day in
age, but the concept has been a part of paranormal
folklore for hundreds of years.
The term itself originated in Germany and
means "double-goer".
It described the phenomenon of seeing someone
who looks exactly like another person, or
perhaps seeing someone who looks exactly like
yourself.
Mostly commonly, the visions of oneself are
reported as happening in your peripheral vision.
Creepeh.
In German folklore, it was thought that seeing
a doppelganger was a bad sign - some kind
of omen that predicted your near death.
And strangely, Abraham Lincoln, Catherine
the Great, and Queen Elizabeth the First were
all reported to have seen their doppelganger
before their death.
One night while relaxing at home, Lincoln
glanced sideways into a mirror and saw another
person, nearly nose to nose with himself in
bed!
The figure looked exactly like him - with
a few exceptions.
He said the figure was slightly shorter and
a little paler than himself.
When he examined the mirror, it went away,
but as he laid back down, the doppelganger
reappeared.
He reported a pang of pain in his head while
he was experiencing this.
Of course, experiences like these have inspired
hundreds of fictional offshoots in film and
television.
How might one explain such spooky strokes
with....yourself?
Some possible answers were accidentally stumbled
upon by doctors who were doing a pre-surgery
evaluation on a patient with epilepsy.
They found that when they applied electrical
stimulation to the patient's temporoparietal
junction, the patient experienced a figure
with a shadow identical to her own in her
presence.
When she was laying down, she felt the figure
was almost nose-to-nose with her.
Sound familiar?
It's almost exactly what Lincoln had described.
The findings were published in the journal
Nature in 2006, where the scientists concluded
that this kind of disturbance in the temporal
lobes may account for some paranormal events.
The case study happened shortly after the
explosion of the infamous "God Helmet", concocted
by neuroscientist Michael Persinger.
Using a similar electrical current on the
temporal lobes, Persinger induced participants
to have a "religious experience".
The experience included the feeling that someone
else was with them -- perhaps watching over
them.
So far, other scientists have failed to replicate
his study.
Thanks for joining me for DNews friends!
Have you ever spotted a doppelganger?
Tell me your stories down below (on our DNews
Facebook page) and I'll see you next time.